pretty straightforward I think yeah
that's I mean it's obviously uh Bishop
D2 King A5 or K3 Bishop A4 Queen takes
B7
it is not it's not ah because there's
there's a rook G3 truck that I missed
this is true
so your final answer is correct
it is not Bishop D2
oh yeah
but I want to play Bishop a free check
and followed by big free Checkmate but
after that that is Rook G3 let's say so
I'm thinking about Queen F3 right now
I'm not sure Bishop takes and it's only
damage free
uh alignments the beautiful one yeah
yeah you're you're nailing this one I
this one I I have yeah queen of three
Bishop of three Bishop yes that's the
one perfect yeah we know three was okay
yeah